so we gave the first
the first part to ana actually really
really a great game
now well carlson's turn okay so this is
their most recent game and tiny bit was
shocking like this game because
they're going to play a world
championship match i mean this will
really speaking less than five months
ago
this cannot be the way that anand is
going to play
in the match i mean this
uh this will be the the women's world
championship match
okay between huefan and anoshinina
okay
hui fun was even a bigger favorite i i
think than
carlson is here but still to imagine
that she will beat the world champion
with all
preparation and still
a world championship match still tiny
bits
different like you know
there are so many other factors that
make the waiting gap
tiny bit difference there is the stress
and people raise up to the event you
know it's like
it's not like a normal i don't know like
let's say an nba playoff like okay the
playoffs and games are even if one team
is way better it's different than the
normal league
so better for anand because look at this
game i mean we will see the last two
games let's start with the most recent
one
so carson played d4 knight f6
okay they went into the nimzo indian
which is
the other uh
in recent years i think that anand
anand is played mainly
the nimzo indian well he's played a lot
but the names nimzo indian
he has played much more i mean the move
order that they play
if knight f3
they they go less for the queens in the
end
they actually go much more for the
queen's gambit declined and actually
that game brought him
the most important most important
victory he had in this line was against
yes
now
the
in the the last game of the 2010 match
the score was five and a half five and a
half
anand played black and just really
didn't want to lose
no nothing is wrong but they kind of
prefer to play more
to play more solid and to play this way
so
so that's where they are heading
yeah play bogo then knight bd2 is a
possibility
bishop and knight bd2 is i think
mainline they want to get the bishops
here i mean okay queens
queens indian is of course a huge one
queen's indian is of course a huge one
which are not
has played but today i think they are
somewhat playing tiny bit more the
queens
in gambit decline
no but of course the the nimso indian is
one opening that offers so many
possibilities for both sides
i mean many white players choose knight
f3 they just don't want to give those
that many
chances or game for black with knight
with bishop before
but i think that's the right approach in
many ways like just big game i mean
quincy two was kasparov favorite
f3 were some great games by shirov in
early 90s
of course knight f3 e3 all-class super
classical line
even some lines with a3 we have seen
quite recently
but okay e3
and knight g2 personally i like this
line for white
the other main lines are
knight f3 d5 bishop d3
cop of his play those for black history
i think
okay d5 is i think a main move here d5
immediately
but it's a matter of taste you know so
what so
like anand doesn't know what he's doing
he played castle
yeah he played here d5
i think here b6 is something that
worth some attention
either b60 or the previous move
maybe it was the previous one
let me actually now you got me wondering
what exactly
no d5 d5 on mov4 i think is what
what is the other major alternative
but the idea of knight g2 is basically
to be able to play a3
and just to recapture with the knight
d5 they play yeah this is main line
i just wonder if what that does
okay and here
they have bishop bishop d6 is a
is another continuation for example
there are some games of nakamura here in
karnik i'm just not certain that the
database is that updated i think
this is for example
galvan kramnik
for melody amber really really strong
strong enough players have played it
yeah there's a bishop d6 is one move and
bishop is seven
and we can actually speak for a second
try to figure out
why why would black play bishop d6
to provoke c5 and then back because he
wants to reduce the
pressure from the center in this line on
the other hand might get some space some
squares
okay and then played bishop e7
and took with the knight
what about take with the pawn is that
legal
looks looks pretty illegal
knight take bishop d2
okay so in general
what would
yes
no yeah
okay so in general what what does black
wanna play here
and then what
and d7 upstate
and then what
no no no we we need to have a plan like
knight to d7 256 just moving the pieces
what what's black's plan here
f5
c5 why c5
that's that's black's plan basically if
you can have few moves to play what
would you play let's say y plays rook c1
okay one looks a one okay one okay well
what you will play you will play days
for example
you'll play days
and you play knight d7 and c5 and black
is totally okay i mean like that black
has less space
therefore by the way the knight on d7
is more useful than on f6
you need to control those squares you
want to play c5
this this is for example we get similar
ideas in
several structures with
queen's gamut here since we mentioned
queen's gambit and let me quickly show
the total variation for example
super duper main line played in so many
world championships
fisher had a game like this against
spassky a great game because power of
karpov cup of caspar of cup of short
many many many many
carlson had some games in this line
nakamura
in the famous game that we mentioned
before topalov
against anand
an unplayed knight e4 which is the last
kill variation
super solid one and actually one which
is very rare
and
that one of the other main lines is b6
with a very simple idea
bishop out knight d7 c5 i played this
when i was seven simplest opening eight
you've changed
super salt
then my chest started deteriorating but
when i was dead i played super solid
openings
it happens to everyone when you're the
one
yes when you're young you always play a
decent line then you say oh this is
interesting i remember a game
in the world championships
he won he won this one
he won this one very decisively
so
this is i think
quite a smart
waiting move
what's going to happen if
g3 gonna be played which is most logical
way i mean we just want to be able to
develop
the bishop how is black going to play
here
c5
okay
c5 let's say i play this move
no but okay
but first of all
i might just take the pawn and ask you
to show me what you have for the pawn
like
what you have for the phone
not clear i mean maybe you do
bishop takes c5 and some compensation
but
no but i think there's much much more
principle approach here for black
but but why is this no but but moves
like c6 i mean it's not about being
solid it's about okay white will play
bishop g2 castle e4 when white plays
default white is going to win the game
by gaining more space more space more
space and more space no checkmate so
yeah you can put all the pieces here
here here
no okay
why will start pushing and it's
that's it
no b6 is important
because after bishop g2
bishop b7
and of course black would be very happy
to exchange the
fianchettos bishop right is
no but then but okay but you you don't
play bishop g2 to play f3
i mean for for example this actually
might be a reasonable move
this can be reasonable
no but f5
f5 is weakening this so so much i would
not play f5
queen b3 or just castle
i mean i i think i think this is a
reasonable way for black to play for
white to play actually you know let's
let's see if we
have any
games in this line exactly it'll be
interesting g3
so they play c5 you all move tiny bit
they play b6 my move tiny bit
b6 several decent players play this
yeah this this is for example
we can just see this quickly this is
this is okay obviously doubt of quite a
strong grandmaster
played against a weaker player and
of course of course allowing
we just said a second ago that allowing
this is wrong
i mean here black is already
equal plus because of this bishop i mean
probably just equal but
i i like a lot e4 here
i think he for his
most principle move to consider here
let's see
yeah
castle i don't like castle so much i
like e4 computers say they are very
close but i think that after castle
black has easy game to thank you
okay
community completely changes
yeah
no but if but e4 has to be played here
okay
so
at least we understand
now
what is the idea of this move
let's try to understand it slowly in our
world
what
would white play after b6 immediately
yes i think i think this is what he
wants to play exactly
because the rook on h1 is not under
attack so if you take with the pawn
we will get just a very normal
position i mean actually i'm not even
certain that i will play here
that i will play hill g3 i might play g3
i might also just play knight c3
immediately
now
if this pawn was on b7
this pawn on b7
black is very happy
i mean the entire mo
most of why to
play
is because this
this square is weak
because b6 has been played and black
will forever either gonna have a bad
bishop here
or to put a bishop o just a weak spot on
c6 that that's the big thing black best
move here
best move here is going to be
pawn back you think
no but seriously if you can play pawn
back and then c6
yes
what about i mean this position reminds
me a lot of uh
you see
we mentioned it a lot but like it seems
like it's a target car where white's
played 92 and bishop d2 which don't seem
that
useful like it seems like black should
be fine here
he's trying to compare like the
differences
in this position right yeah
but let's see i'll play this move
maybe
and bishop to g2
okay
i mean i'm thinking we actually we
actually
two minutes before
like we were just really comparing those
those structures and those lines exactly
because they're you're absolutely right
the resemblance it's exactly a
different version
so knight d7 was played actually let's
see if we have any games with b6
no many games with b6
no b but no b6 at all that's a bit too
bizarre that nobody played b6
okay i'm going to question that
let me see this one for a second one b6
i can't believe that knight g3 is the
reason yeah
okay but no no nobody okay doc mccoy is
a strong player
yeah he took on c3 we also had a
previous game by a nun taking on
taking on c3 i think it was another
onion
okay
oh man ben is going to tell me that i
need to
click on that to get it back in the
board right ben let's see if we can do
it now he's going to be happy
okay
so bishop d2 is quite
some sort of a waiting move
i i think that okay if take take in c5
probably some microscopic advantage for
white if he even takes and gets somewhat
symmetrical position
b6
somehow
i would consider i mean i do not believe
that this is bad position for black
another played this one horrible played
97 that was played before g3
maybe now take
but
now they're going to be a bit problem
because then it will be tiny bit like
you know this big catalan bishop
and not easy to see what to do with the
c8 bishop and then played now b6
maybe it was better to play it a move
before okay so we got exactly the
position that
you mentioned tartar cover if you really
stick to the 97
that's exactly
absolutely the position that we get
but
but it's interesting first of all white
bishop is on d2 and not out of the pawn
chain
but carson carson played it in
a great way
if someone seemed a move then shush and
if not
then just thinking about our last
comment
huh he was there
you were there
okay
so what did he play
bishop before you see it like it's live
live you know like reporting from tall
memorial julian
okay no but that's but but this is so
logical you know
we are looking in tiny bit discussing
anand and katherine and the match but
also we can take tiny bits for our chess
i mean a lot right i mean other than
oh wait there's going to be a match
starting in two days two and a half days
and this and this is to our chest
i just said a minute ago without even
remembering what was played in the game
hey this bishop is not out of the pawn
chain
if we said that we don't need to say
more okay
so let's exchange it
we don't need to because to play that we
just need to understand you know
is this the world prettiest bishop
probably not
you know it's not it's not
but it would be very nice i mean
actually this is working amazingly well
for
for white this exchange of the bishops
and actually and and this is already
just better for white i mean the way
that
this game went
i wonder
i mean what happens after c5 we have we
have to ge
i mean i really want to figure this one
okay most likely
actually i i thought it most likely it's
going to take but
i think it should take because if this
move
okay i can play c4
let me just for now play this
no he wants you want to weaken the pawns
he will get he will get he wants to play
against their hanging pawns
that's what he wants to provoke
so that's what he wants to provoke but
okay see if i you know the funny thing
is that i don't know if c5 is better or
not i mean i know that i not played this
game so horrible was incr really bad but
probably every every club player
doesn't matter what the level you know
will play c5 without much thinking hey i
push a point attacking the bishop and
the world champion played something else
if c5 is better it will be really funny
but okay let's go be let's take you know
first of all let's see take take
and bishop here
so this is classical play against the
hanging pawns and
no maybe not so pleasant
knight b6
castle
knight f4
rooks rook c1
and white should be better here
but
okay i'll play queen d7 you know
i'll i'll try to
to defend this one a bit for black
knight f4
gluck fd8
bishop well
bishop a5
but if bishop a5 i i maybe
i'll play rook c8 i mean
i mean the thing is that i have to yeah
i have to play d4 because there are also
some ideas of a tiny attack here i have
to play d4
or at least at least be able to threaten
in some moment to play d4
yeah bishop a5
maybe bishop f6
or maybe even d4
i'm not certain i mean somehow i prefer
white but
you know let's just get let's just get
yeah
computers say white is no that that's
what we feel okay but
okay i mean not
i mean okay it's freight whatever he
knows and that's our okay zero some
somewhat somewhat more comfortable for
white
all right
yeah i mean i i would prefer of course
white here but
this is nothing you know too dramatic
actually i want to see what
yeah okay c5
actually i wonder then maybe knight b6
which i played was a bit less accurate
knight f6 i thought i thought that i
don't want the knight to be
threatened to capture
okay
knight f6 or knight b6 in both ways
no this is funny
i mean i'll i'll just show this like
what the computer is saying
like i wonder who who here is really
going to play knight f6
and now play and now play g5
okay so knight f6 rookie okay so very
solid doesn't want to create any
weaknesses doesn't want to give anything
on the other hand he also doesn't want
to take on before
c6
maybe c6 was not that great i don't know
something was not that great because he
got killed here
but what could you have played
a5 forcing the exchange but creating
some weakness
then you're gonna have like
some weakness
this one's gonna be super duper weak
okay rookie one
okay so play 26 first no
oh you are afraid that you will play
like knight c3
that's actually a very good point but
this is bad
dude i mean like
i mean this
i mean
like i said before
if you take this one here
and you can play c6 and a6 of course
black is better
i mean just take this pawn back and be
able to play here
doesn't matter even if white doesn't
have double pawns
totally okay for black very very nice
this hole here that's why
white is waiting
for this b6 move
and then capturing
this this huge hole over there no this
this is unpleasant
maybe something like bishop d6 here just
just bishop d6 and waiting a bit
i mean it's a bit those are the types of
positions you know this is
there is a reason why i chose those two
games
where anand is winning or where a nun
can win exactly the same type of game
that we've seen in the previous hour
complicated messi
defense attack i mean okay
again we'll see in which form he was but
in 2008 against kramnik
it was just incredible
those type of positions
yeah look c8 i guess
go back
like see to be honest c6 if i hadn't
seen the game and seen how it went oh c6
looks super logical but i just know that
he somehow got crushed a little bit
after that so
but
c6 looks logical
c6 take take okay so what is white's
what is white's play here i mean there
are two
two ways actually to play him
huh
playful c6 perfect like some b4
knight here here maybe
maybe aiming for e5 putting pressure
against c6 right this is one plane very
very normal
there's another plane that that carson
actually
proved to be just really really strong
so there's another idea if we see the
knight on e2 and we understand
some potential for f3 for
rookie 1
knight f4
yeah
somehow combining everything
we want to put pressure here so we
mentioned knight
b4 and so on
and this is bad bishop
yeah
the thing is that
the thing is that if black if black
would have played this move
okay nothing pass
now f3 is not that impressive
why
what would black play here very
logically
okay and then what
yeah rook a2 e8 is to start
but also some something like c5 usually
we would say c5 is just a weakness
but
this is also weak now
and this is blocked
so c5 is much more possible i mean of
course okay e8 is the move but after
this
after
bishop c8
he played queen a4
maybe here once again bishop d7 was a
possibility
yes
i mean the thing is that it's not really
easy to find any counter play for black
hair
okay so let let's play rook a8
stopping
white play
okay what about this move
bishop
no
no i'm not no no not putting the move on
the board i'm sorry
you know
yeah
also white might in some lines go queen
before i mean black might not exchange
but
remember when we said b6 and this is
going to be weak forever
that bishop on g2 is actually very
pretty in those lines prettier than on
d3
no this is just a bit uncomfortable for
black
okay i not felt
i don't felt it
maybe just some g6 and king g7 just
a tiny bit
probably i will if
up to me i'll play g6 king g7 maybe
thinking about creating something here
that's what black usually does
bishop c8 was not really bad
but maybe now this move was really wrong
because what happened in the last two
moves
it took all the pieces from
this square
and this coil
tiny bit too much actually you know we
had the rook on e7 develop why why
didn't wanna play this i know why i
think he was afraid of queen before
he didn't want to play this position
because now he's supposed to exchange
that's what bothered him and actually b5
is an idea
yeah actually actually actually this
this screen before is tiny annoying i
mean i'm just looking and thinking
yeah
computer is not afraid okay he wants to
play knight d3 on thank you
yeah this screen before to me would be
more annoying than knight d3
but okay
no
bishop c8 not so but but if this is
correct and i think this is correct then
bishop
c8 is not right move then he should have
played our g6
okay
bishop c8 rook c7
but now he's toast
yeah i mean i remember
anand said like sorry carlson said that
after f3 he just couldn't see
anything for black pretty much
because amazing
there were two two pieces here
i mean seriously what to play now
against this so we had the idea in our
head maybe an und overlooked this idea
yeah those are the types of positions
that i think
carlson will be really
seeking to get in the game like no big
tactics no huge dynamics kind of solid
simple
and he is just finding the right plane
or shifting play
but what to play here to survive
i mean problem with c5 it opens the
diagonal e4 comes with e5
maybe not much to do to survive
bishop is 6
e4
take
maybe not take but
let's just see for a second if
computer has any smart idea
yeah but g5 yeah we were joking about g5
and c5 also impossible no it's just
if you need to play g5 here
yeah you you just you just
wrong spot no we joked about it before
no nobody
maybe carson can play g5 himself but
yeah
but this is amazing how he how he lost
him
just
amazing there's a famous game the one i
mentioned caspar of anderson similar
idea with rook on c7
and he played d5 you know maybe just for
illustration we'll show it after this
game will be actually very good and he
won material
yeah this this is really strong
this is the heart of his idea
in this
move yeah just just resign here
rook d65 rookie 7 take on d5 white
works on their files
no
are there any possibilities for some
blockade maybe
not really
yeah this is what i'm thinking amazing
this dude
i thought i mean if take
then actually rook d6 for a second
and then take back
is this possible let's see what happens
after take
is it possible to blockade at all
yeah maybe something like dc
and now
look here and some luft
and if he gets his big dream
he will get into a rook end game pawn
down and survive something
no but dc5 like no survival nowhere
yeah
no so this
this is not pretty
just resign yeah just i mean it's just
going to play this and either come from
here or just take the pawn
i mean if the rooks were otherwise
maybe tiny bit to play but
yeah so this
this is i think the last game that they
played
tiny bit scary
you know i mean i i remember
i remember actually
grand master rogers rogers that was here
for the thingfield cup he said that he
has a flight to
to the women's world championship match
and he will be arriving like to the
last third of the tournament the match
well there was no last third of the
match and it was best out of 10 and was
over by game seven so i actually don't
know if you made it or not yeah five and
a half one in the apples
so
i don't know
speaking about the structure let's see
the kasparov
gospel of anderson game that we have
spoken so we will say bye bye to
kasparov and adam for a second
d496 c4
yeah today by the way today we airline
align it is much more popular for people
that want to play very solid
like for example
some important games are by
my fellow
gm residency varacobian
that's
a very strong grandmaster playing
for the u.s olympic team
he plays this
and many other strong players i mean
actually some big games carlos and beta
rhonian in this line and nakamura bitter
onion and some big big games in
in this line and actually already
because power of carp have played this
then they take take because what's
black's idea okay if knight f3
he wants to transpose to
normal position that was supposed to be
okay for black
so take
take and bishop f4
actually there was just now a game a
month and a half ago in the paris grand
prix
nakamura beat
i mean okay queen c2 is a move here
and also this by the way was played in
saint louis in the match nakamura pune
off so
lots of
big names playing this yeah nakamura
played something like this and h4 which
is one of the main lines
so but but this bishop is seven is if
players don't want to get into
same same
type of play like in kasparov anderson
then bishop e7 first
yeah i think this is just very pleasant
line for white i mean maybe if black
plays perfect
it can be close to okay but
i
i think quite it yeah and f3
i mean very very simple ideas
they were played 25 years ago i mean
okay they'll probably play before that
but
because power play certainly everyone
knows
yeah he is he's waiting he's waiting
with e4
i think mainly because
he doesn't want black to play c5
and the king will be on this diagonal
and tiny bit so his tiny bit making some
preparation if c5 now
just take
move the queen and blockade i'm just
better
but there are some lines that this is
the way to be played
and what now i mean there are many moves
that can be played here
if you remember
if you remember
white wants to play for
about an hour and an hour and a half ago
however
we were looking at
critical game in
in carlson anand the great game that
anand won with black and at some point
there was
a move after queen d6 by white
94
you were asking me
carlson sacrificed the exchange
you remember the moment when he
sacrificed exchange what happens if
bishop f1 and we got some aggressive
suggestions g4 by julian
bishop takes c4
and we suggested
quind8 to fight for the dark squares
look at this position
white pieces
the knights they are on dark square so
they are all controlling light squares
the bishop controls light squares
e4 is coming
very typical to this line we need
something to
protect the dark squares
so first queen f2 very similar to the
queen d8 which we suggested in the other
game which then julian was really happy
the computer said that it was the best
move
no this this idea is very typical we
want to play on light squares everything
is controlling the light world i need
something for dark squares
yeah and this this exactly position and
exactly this move reminded me
this game where carlson played d5 and
kasparov played
d5
and after take
very very strong intermediate move
bishop b5
no rook d6 because e5
rook c7
take
this is the real beauty
he doesn't want to exchange
and now he has two threats what are his
two threads
d6 is a nice threat right winning hook
not bad
and the second one
but a thousand pieces i mean here
queen taking seven take a pawn
yes yes
dude that's how we win chess games you
think only checkmate no no it's winning
that pawn
and
went on to win
take another pawn
two connected pawns not really bad
not really and what you do with past
pawns
just push them
push push push
push oh yeah he's not bad
push push push
but
very similar the idea of the d5 brake
different positions but a lot a lot of
this thing
all righty well you know
maybe tomorrow we will see some more
games
and then you know we will let them play
on fight and see
see what's going there
you